British police revealed the substance
used to poison a former Russian spy was
a nerve agent news that a nerve agent
was used in the attack on Sergey scree
Paul and his 33 year old daughter is
making headlines in Britain there in
critical condition a police officer who
is on the scene is also hospitalized
Elizabeth Palmer is outside New Scotland
Yard in London where the
counterterrorism force is investigating
Elizabeth good morning good morning yes
as soon as the police were able to
confirm that it was a nerve agent the
huge overriding question became so
whodunit Britain's Home Secretary amber
Rudd reacted this morning to the already
widespread speculation that the Russian
state was involved the use of a nerve
agent on UK soil is a brazen and
reckless act we will respond in a robust
and appropriate manner once we ascertain
who was responsible here is Sergei
scrape all two weeks ago shopping at his
local grocery store not acting like a
man who feared for his life arrested in
Moscow for spying in 2004 he came to the
UK six years later and settled down to
an apparently quiet life in Salisbury
until Sunday when in this park he and
his daughter were attacked in broad
daylight with a lethal chemical it's a
very risky way to try and kill somebody
Jerry Smith is a former UN chemical
weapons inspector why go to all the
trouble of using a nerve agent there are
very much simpler ways to kill someone
it's not a covert assassination that's
taking place here this is an old home
but assassination and perhaps there are
wider messaging issues that are taking
place so somebody was trying to send a
message for example it was a nerve agent
that was used to kill North Korean
leader Kim Jong Un's half-brother in a
Malaysian airport last year if the
chemical used in Salisbury was
military-grade says Smith then probably
a state maybe Russia was involved but
there is an outside chance a civilian
chemist could make something equally
lethal Anna Massey Hall is a former
British intelligence officer the media
and our politicians
no stampeding towards you no it has to
be Russia it's always Russia there are
many many other players for example
perhaps agents enemy agents from
scruples own espionage days who have
links to organized crime
maybe corrupt militaries scale what does
it does sound like something out of a
movie thank you very much